port d'armes je vous le répète n'étaient
pas liées à la sécurité du président de
la république mais à ma sécurité
personnelle
monsieur benalla ça n'est pas ce que
nous a dit le préfet de police
et ça n'est pas ce que mentionne le
l'arrêté du préfet de police sur le port
d'armes mais j'entends votre réponse et
nous en prenons acte
mais simplement dites nous pourquoi vous
auriez été plus exposés que d'autres
collaborateurs du président de la
république à des risques qui auraient
justifié pour vous et pour vous seul
l'obtention d'un permis de port d'armes
alors la première des choses je vous
précise je ne parlerai pas des menaces
qui ont pesé à un moment pour ma
sécurité personnelle encore aujourd'hui
la deuxième des choses c'est que j'ai
été exposé médiatiquement plus que
l'ensemble de n'importe quel
collaborateur pendant la campagne
présidentielle et 3e des choses je n'ai
pas pu bénéficier tout de suite pour
nécessité absolue de service d'un
appartement à l'admr dès lors que vous
habitez à l'alma que vous êtes
collaborateur du président vous êtes
protégé par les gendarmes il ya un
chauffeur qui vous ramène chez vous le
soir qui est armé
c'est le cas du secrétaire général c'est
le cas du directeur de cabinet c'est le
cas du chef de cabinet c'est le cas d'un
certain nombre de collaborateurs vous
avez un service s'appelle la régulation
et qui vous emmène sont des gendarmes
ils ont une arme à la ceinture ils n'ont
pas pour le plaisir
ils n'ont pour des raisons de sécurité
dès lors que vous exercez à la
présidence de la république
vous êtes exposés donc moi j'ai fait le
choix de conduire même ma voiture et de
me protéger moi même parce que j'en
avais les capacités et je me suis jamais
servi d'un chauffeur de la régulation
qui sont des gendarmes armés et qui
accompagnent les membres du cabinet de
chez eux le matin à l'elysée le soir et
de l'elysée le soir jusqu'à chez eux
donc ils garantissent leur sécurité et
je rentrerai pas plus dans les détails
parce qu'après on va toucher à quelque
chose qu'il est important bien sûr ce
monsieur benalla je vous repose la
question pouvez-vous nous certifier que
vous n'avez jamais porter votre arme
lors des déplacements publics
du président de la république je ne
parle pas des autres circonstances mais
lors de ses déplacements publics où vous
n'exercez aucune mission direct de
sécurité c'est ça alors si j'étais en
qualité de précurseur et je partais de
man domicile directement sur du
déplacement
il a pu arriver que j'ai une arme sur
moi c'est possible ça a pu arriver